Traduttore: Michele Gianella
Revisore: Marco Caresia
Questo è il nostro mondo.
Il mondo che vogliamo conoscere
per avere una possibilità
di vivere meglio, di vivere più felici,
perché questo è quello
che vogliamo tutti.
Ma, per poterlo conoscere,
dobbiamo studiarlo
e per poterlo studiare dobbiamo misurare
il mondo che ci circonda,
quindi il mondo
che noi vogliamo conoscere,
il mondo che però vogliamo studiare.
E studiare il mondo vuol dire
misurare il mondo,
cioè quello che è stato
sempre fatto dai cartografi.
La cartografia si è da sempre occupata
della misura del mondo,
della misura del mondo prima
e della sua rappresentazione dopo,
perché lo possiamo conoscere.
Questa misura del mondo
per tanti secoli è rimasta invariata:
vedete due immagini
molto diverse tra di loro
dal punto di vista temporale,
ma le misure del mondo
venivano fatte sempre da terra,
dopodiché, a partire dall’inizio
del secolo scorso,
abbiamo cominciato a volare,
- gli esperimenti
dei fratelli Wright, all’inizio -
abbiamo cominciato a prendere
le immagini del mondo da sopra di noi,
prima gli aerei, poi i satelliti
– 1957, Sputnik –
adesso sta iniziando una nuova era,
l’era degli Unmanned Aerial Vehicle (UAV),
quelli che molti chiamano,
in modo più semplice, droni.
Ma torniamo per un attimo ai satelliti,
che sono la realtà di oggi.
L’ultima immagine che vedete
in basso a destra
è un satellite,
è il satellite Worldview 3.
Worldview 3 è un satellite
che vola abbastanza basso,
vola a circa 600 km
di altezza rispetto a noi,
ha molti sensori, tra questi sensori
un sensore particolare
che è una fotocamera con la quale,
come diciamo noi scherzando,
la Terra si fa i suoi selfie.
E queste immagini sono immagini
del tutto particolari e spettacolari,
perché da quell’altezza
riusciamo a riprendere il mondo
con un dettaglio dell’ordine dei 30 cm.
Quindi, un qualsiasi oggetto
sulla superficie della Terra
che è più grande di 30 cm
viene ripreso da Worldview.
Però Worldview non è l’unico satellite
che monitora la Terra.
Qua vedete un’immagine della Terra
circondata dai suoi satelliti artificiali
che sono operativi,
quindi non sono tutti corpi
che orbitano intorno alla Terra
in cui dovremmo aggiungere i debris,
i satelliti che ormai
non sono operativi, e così via.
Sono solo quelli operativi:
ognuno di loro ha moltissimi sensori,
e quindi c’è un monitoraggio
in tempo reale della nostra Terra.
Però quello che dobbiamo dire
è che queste immagini
non sono immediatamente utilizzabili
da noi per mappare il mondo,
perché per quanto abbiamo
dei computer molto intelligenti,
il computer non è ancora
- e probabilmente non sarà mai -
intelligente come l’uomo, per cui
abbiamo bisogno ancora degli uomini
che mettano i loro occhi e la loro mente
su queste immagini,
per poterle interpretare.
Allora la cartografia è cambiata
tantissimo, negli anni,
per quanto riguarda le tecnologie.
Ma è cambiata anche moltissimo
la sua mission:
all’inizio la cartografia era costruita
per scopi militari o per scopi catastali,
quindi per poter mappare il mondo
e imporre della tassazione
legata alla proprietà.
Poi, a partire dagli anni ’70,
le cose sono cambiate
e si è incominciato
ad usare la cartografia
anche per scopi diversi,
ad esempio scopi di pianificazione,
progettazione del territorio e così via.
Ma la vera rivoluzione
è [avvenuta] 11 anni fa – 2004.
Nel 2004 nasce questo progetto,
che si chiama OpenStreetMap,
e l’ideatore è questo, allora,
ragazzo che vedete qua, Steve Coast,
allora neo laureato d’informatica
a UCL - University College of London.
Assieme ai suoi amici, Steve comincia
a portare avanti questo progetto
che è il progetto
della mappa libera del mondo.
L’idea fondamentale di Steve
e dei suoi amici,
idea che attecchisce immediatamente
a livello globale,
soprattutto grazie a un movimento,
il movimento dei sistemi informativi
e delle informazione geografica libera
e a codice aperto – Open Source –
che fanno subito propria quest’idea
e da pochi contributori,
all’inizio del 2004,
si passa a un numero di contributori
che oggi supera i 2 milioni.
Due milioni di persone,
in giro per il mondo,
che mappano la nostra Terra.
Quali sono le idee fondamentali
di Steve e di OpenStreetMap?
La prima idea è
che l’informazione geografica,
quella che una volta era la cartografia,
e che adesso, detto in termini moderni,
si chiama informazione geografica.
L'informazione geografica
sta diventando pervasiva:
sempre più gli eventi, i fenomeni
che accadono a livello mondale,
sono eventi e fenomeni
che trovano la loro contestualizzazione
e il loro significato
se sono collocati
dal punto di vista spaziale.
Applicazioni pratiche?
La navigazione con le nostre macchine,
che ormai facciamo con i navigatori
satellitari e con le mappe;
la navigazione individuale
che diventerà sempre più importante;
i servizi basati sulla localizzazione,
nei quali siamo solo all’inizio.
Ma la seconda idea importante
è che, se noi vogliamo
poter utilizzare questi dati,
se vogliamo che questi dati
siano dati liberi,
allora questi dati
dobbiamo crearceli da noi.
Quindi, a questo punto
il motto forte di OpenStreetMap
è che OpenStreetMap è la mappa
creata da persone come te,
per essere usata liberamente
da chiunque nel mondo.
E come si può creare queste mappe?
Lo si può fare individualmente,
ma è molto più divertente
e molto più bello
farlo tutti assieme.
E allora possiamo organizzare
quelli che sono i Mapping parties,
e quindi è questa la prima parola
che voglio che impariate.
Mapping parties vuol dire
ritrovarsi tutti assieme
e mappare, mappare con uno scopo.
Ad esempio, quello che vedete
in questa immagine
è un mapping party a Osaka,
per costruire la mappa della resilienza,
quindi cittadini, scienziati,
amministratori,
membri della protezione civile locale
e così via
si trovano, girano per la città
e individuano quali sono i punti
che dovranno essere utilizzati
nel caso di emergenza
e quali sono i punti che potrebbero
presentare difficoltà e così via:
creano la mappa della resilienza.
Il motto è: mappare il mondo.
Però voglio raccontarvi anche
un’altra storia, a questo punto:
la storia di Haiti, di quando
un terribile terremoto distrusse Haiti.
E allora a questo punto
si doveva intervenire,
ma per poter intervenire
bisognava conoscere come muoversi
in un territorio la cui morfologia
era cambiata a seguito del terremoto.
A questo punto alcuni gruppi legati
a OpenStreetMap ebbero questa idea,
ottenere delle immagini satellitari
ad alta risoluzione,
per mezzo dell’intercessione
di organizzazioni internazionali,
mettere queste immagini
sulla piattaforma di OpenStreetMap,
che è una piattaforma,
dal punto di vista tecnologico,
molto avanzata,
perché infatti vi ricordate
che Steve Coast è un informatico
e vi ricordate che tutto questo
nasce nell’ambito del software geografico
libero e a codice aperto.
Quindi la piattaforma è molto complicata,
ma il suo utilizzo è molto semplice:
può farlo chiunque,
non bisogna essere dei nerd.
La piattaforma è a prova di bambino;
o meglio, forse, a prova di nonno.
Allora a questo punto vengono messe
queste immagini nuove di Haiti modificata
su questa piattaforma e viene lanciata
una call a livello mondiale:
tutti i volontari si mettono a mappare.
In poche ore, la mappa di Haiti è pronta.
Una mappa importantissima che serve
per capire come muoversi sul territorio
e che serve in definitiva
per salvare delle vite.
Dopo questo si sono costituite task force
in giro dappertutto nel mondo
e ogni volta che c’è
un evento catastrofico
tutti i volontari si mettono a mappare
per poter costruire
il nuovo assetto del territorio.
Ma non dobbiamo andare tanto lontano
per fare queste cose:
nell’immagine che vedete è descritto
quello che è successo qui,
proprio a Como,
al Politecnico di Milano, questa primavera
a seguito del terremoto del Nepal.
Ci siamo trovati in tanti,
abbiamo imparato
come mappare tutti insieme
e abbiamo contribuito anche noi
a creare la mappa che è servita
a tutti i volontari sul posto
per poter intervenire.
Ma in questo siete molto fortunati,
devo dire, perché casualmente
questo TEDx viene a coincidere
con l’inizio della settimana
della consapevolezza geografica.
Una settimana che è stata decisa da tutte
le organizzazioni di OpenStreetMap
che gravitano intorno a OpenStreetMap.
A partire dal 15 ci saranno
tutta una serie di eventi,
in giro per il mondo, almeno 100.
Eventi di mapping
che noi chiamiamo mapathon,
è questa la seconda parola
che voglio che impariate.
Il mapathon vuol dire
trovarsi tutti in un posto,
ognuno con un computer,
perché questa è la cosa fondamentale,
per mappare tutti insieme.
Quindi, se siete interessati,
giovedì prossimo,
non tanto lontano da qua, a Milano
– Politecnico di Milano -
faremo un mapathon.
E di cosa ci occuperemo
in questo mapathon?
Se saremo così sfortunati
che ci sarà qualche emergenza,
dovremo occuparci di questa emergenza;
ma se invece saremo fortunati
e in questi giorni non succederà niente,
non rimarremo inoperosi,
perché c’è un altro bellissimo progetto
al quale potremo contribuire,
che si chiama Missing Maps.
Il progetto Missing Maps
è un progetto che si occupa
di quelle aree del mondo
che sono aree dimenticate,
ma che sono aree fragili
a causa di catastrofi naturali
o di altro tipo
che possono abbattersi su queste aree,
ma di solito sono anche
le aree più povere del mondo
e quindi non hanno le infrastrutture
e la strumentazione come abbiamo noi.
Allora a questo punto
quello che possiamo creare,
in questi mapathon,
sono le mappe di queste aree
dimenticate del mondo, per essere pronti
nel caso dovesse succedere
qualsiasi evento catastrofico.
Questa comunità,
questa grande e generosa comunità,
formata soprattutto da volontari,
non si occupa però soltanto del mapping
in preparazione dei disastri,
o durante i disastri.
Vogliamo fare qualcosa di più,
vogliamo anche avere un occhio positivo
rispetto a quello che succede.
Ma allora ci sono anche molti altri modi
per poter contribuire
al mapping del mondo.
Per mancanza di tempo
ve ne cito soltanto due:
Il primo [è] la biodiversità.
Biodiversità soprattutto
in ambito urbano:
non possiamo, né dobbiamo pensare
che la biodiversità
sia soltanto in posti lontani,
che non conosciamo.
Esiste anche una biodiversità
molto vicino a noi
e noi dobbiamo imparare a conoscerla,
apprezzarla e tutelarla.
Questo progetto, Urbangene, è un progetto
del Politecnico Federale di Losanna
ed è un progetto nel quale
si chiede a tutti i collaboratori,
è sufficiente avere un computer
per poterci accedere,
di inserire i dati sulla biodiversità
nell’area intorno a Losanna.
Il secondo progetto di cui
vi voglio parlare, invece,
è un progetto di casa nostra,
ed è un progetto, a questo punto, invece,
di tipo culturale e turistico.
Ma un turismo di tipo diverso,
un turismo che si chiama slow tourism.
Lo slow tourism è un qualcosa
di simile allo slow food,
è un utilizzo del territorio
che sia un utilizzo consapevole.
Quello che vogliamo fare
è non aggredire il territorio,
ma muoverci in modo lento sul territorio
quindi camminando, andando a cavallo,
andando in bicicletta
si ha modo di guardarsi intorno,
e guardandosi intorno
si ha modo di capire
quelle che sono tutte le ricchezze
del territorio che ci circonda,
magari delle piccole ricchezze
o magari delle ricchezze
che sono ricchezze
per noi, per i nostri amici,
sono valori per noi
e magari altri non hanno considerato.
Oppure si può cominciare a vedere
se ci sono delle emergenze sul territorio,
e cominciare a segnalarle.
Tutto questo
viene riassunto in un progetto,
che è un progetto alla sua fine
che si chiama il progetto
“I cammini della via Regina”.
La via Regina è un percorso storico,
che parte dall’Italia
per andare verso il Nord Europa.
Via Regina è una strada
che già esisteva in epoca romana
e che è stata percorsa
da tantissimi personaggi.
A partire dalla Via Regina,
che corre lungo la sponda occidentale
del lago di Como,
si dipartono tantissimi sentieri
e percorsi che vanno verso la Svizzera,
percorsi trasfrontalieri, che sono
percorsi ricchi di cultura e di storia,
attraversati nel tempo
da pellegrini, da contrabbandieri,
da persone normali come noi.
In questo progetto via Regina
abbiamo voluto aggiungere
una parte di mapping collaborativo,
quindi esiste una app
che tutti voi potete utilizzare,
andando sul sito di via Regina,
per andare in giro, in questi territori,
aggiungere le vostre informazioni
sul territorio,
in modo tale che queste informazioni
siano immediatamente mappate
e visibili da chiunque
su un sito Internet,
dove abbiamo una mappa collaborativa
che cresce di giorno in giorno.
In conclusione, come vedete,
c’è tanta possibilità
per poter partecipare
a questi progetti di mapping
assieme a noi.
Una volta i cartografi erano quelli
che partivano e andavano in giro
per esplorare nuovi mondi
e cartografare nuovi mondi.
Adesso i cartografi
possono stare a casa loro,
possono stare nella loro città
e portare a casa loro, e nella loro città,
il mondo.
E perché lo facciamo?
Lo facciamo perché tutti insieme
vogliamo disegnare un mondo
che sia più libero,
condiviso e partecipato.
Allora se qualcuna di queste storie
vi è piaciuta,
quello che posso dire
è che potete venire con noi.
Voi sarete i prossimi cartografi,
perché adesso tocca a noi.
(Applausi)